après deux semaines d'audience les
révélations à la commission rouleau ont
encore de quoi étonner cette fois la
surprise vient de cet avocat qui
conseillait les organisateurs du convoi
des camionnettes
[Musique]
des policiers sympathiques à la cause du
convoi dévoilait des informations
confidentielles aux manifestants et aux
organisateurs il allait que les fuites
provenaient de la police d'Ottawa de la
Police provinciale de l'Ontario de la
GRC et même du service canadien du
renseignement de sécurité
recevaient des informations cruciales
comme des détails sur les opérations
policières planifiées permettant aux
organisateurs de se préparer
l'avocat a même eu accès à une copie
d'un courriel de haut gradé de la Police
provinciale de l'Ontario qui exposait
des tensions avec le service de plus
d'Ottawa des failles qui ont de quoi
inquiéter selon cette expert il peut
avoir un danger imminent
pour les policiers qui sont déployés sur
votre terrain
c'était du bloquer et estomacé c'est
aujourd'hui qui devrait déclencher une
enquête chercher à identifier les
sources de ces fuites là parce que c'est
pas acceptable mais le coup de main aux
manifestants ne sait pas arrêter là cet
ancien militaire qui n'était plus dans
l'armée au moment du convoi a expliqué à
la commission comment il a mis ses
compétences logistiques au service des
organisateurs
d'approvisionnement en essence en
nourriture et en argent pour les
manifestants du convoi notamment en
parallèle les autorités devaient
composer avec des organisateurs du
convoi imprévisible connu pour leurs
propos incendiaires sur les médias
sociaux
tout ça va finir avec des balles avec la
mets le sulfureux packing sur les médias
sociaux des propos pris hors contexte
assurent-ils aujourd'hui il nie que ce
soit un appel à la violence et se
justifie parlant plutôt de scénarios
possibles une prédiction si les gens
sont empêchés de manifester
déjà les corps policiers en avaient
plein les bras surpris par l'envergure
de la manifestation et occupé à
surveiller les différents groupes
installés à Ottawa mais les fuites dans
leur propre rente exposent l'ampleur des
failles qui plombaient la réponse
policière ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada
Ottawa